première rsa va tout lâcher le métro et
métro
me sens utile je t'amène les tarés qui
arrêtent à poubelles qui s'est seulement
comaga ses fruits dès que commencer
[Musique]
moi ça a changé nos vies au complet ce
qui a changé la vie de brigitte et de
ses collègues de l'organisme
communautaire mois son valet c'est la
création du programme de récupération en
supermarché le prs les épiceries n'diaye
fruits légumes pains et avec le prs
maintenant on peut récupérer via un
produit congelé du produit laitier
donc on peut donner à notre clientèle
une plus grande variété de produits ce
qu'on avait peu avant c'est comme le
lait nous on n'a plus alors blain qu on
peut la main du lait on peut remédier au
gour terre-plein denrées qu'on avait pas
chez moi
le réseau des banques alimentaires du
québec a déployé ce programme il y a
deux
une collaboration entre les chaînes
d'alimentation et les boissons du québec
permet de ramasser au quotidien les
denrées périssables depuis 2007 qu'on
aurait mis à moisson va laisser trente
deux mille cinq cents kilos de
nourriture qui correspond à 60 et 5000
repos qui était donné pour les gens dans
le besoin dans la vallée une grande
fierté pour mon équipe et moi dans le
fond de remettre les produits et vendus
à place cayman des matières organiques
ou dans les déchets
en effet les carrières et maxi
maintenant
chez maxi les chiffres ont explosé
depuis l'arrivée du programme de
récupération en supermarché passant de
2200 kg de denrées à dix mille kilos
l'an dernier notre mission c'est de
nourrir tout le monde
avec de pouvoir aider notre communauté
comment comme on fait avec moi son valet
ça me fait grand plaisir
[Musique]
plusieurs restaurants et de petites
épiceries contribue également à la
collecte dans une petite région ce n'est
qu'un beaucoup de gens travaillent au
salaire minimum est souvent le seul
poste budgétaire compressible dans un
foyer c'est la nourriture alors on va
commencer par réduire c'est que l'on
consomme au niveau de l'alimentation
mais pour 6 remplacer ça et c'est là que
les banques alimente al comptoirs
alimentaires peuvent venir ton hyde
jeudi c'est jour de distribution
le matin on s'affaire à préparer les
boîtes et gens doivent s'inscrire on
nous vendent aussi preuve de revenus moi
ça valait bonjour j accueille dans mon
bureau et je donne des petits cartons
selon leur situation de vie et à et
hambourg chercher leurs services est ce
que le cri en terme de qualité de jeu
final est prisonnier où il est fait
l'eau maintenant fait à tous les jours
en fait le trade pour la qualité mais
quand on fait le service au fait
toujours un deuxième prix ça se peut
qu'il ait fait restaurer la transforma
fait les paniers a fait une cuisine
transformation feltri matin 5 aliments
de fribourg comme routeur haut et ça
arrive les gens
notre dernier service un frigo
communautaire remporter d'autres
clientes et une clientèle différente ça
ça permet d'aider encore plus de
personnes
la petite équipe ne saurait se passer de
l'aide précieuse de bénévoles mal et un
bénévole c'est du monde heureux demande
qui vivent longtemps qu'en fait on a
deux vestes haut rhin qui qu'ils nous
préparent leur ai sein de chaque sous
peu et finalement comment chercher le
matin dans les paniers oui dans les
services on est médecin dans les bois
trop tôt oui vous allez voir le club a
bien terminé le s'impressionner le cd
bon ça semble un peu de couleurs durant
des patates c'est quoi ce départ n'aura
cédé tourner d'autres coulées japon mais
vous savez ça oui beaucoup
valoriser ses valeurs moi j'ai laisé
cours des gens c'est moi qui donne les
services dans l'après midi l'une
présente service aux gens qui j'ai
beaucoup d'écho c'est un panier
individuel oui vous avez l'habitude de
venir ici ou oui assez régulièrement et
qu'est ce que vous trouvez absolument
celle là est fraîche deux journées
contre x car il n'a pas de la presse il
ya beaucoup de mets préparés qui ont été
préparés pour le manière houara tient
finalement ce débat s'il est beau panier
devenir parce que le jeu solo je n'ai
peut-être pas 70 à 75 kg à ce que je
vais te chercher l'épicerie drake à main
puis 75 espèces sur deux fins de semaine
plus être social ça marche pas
c'est un fait
qu'est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
vraiment un bon gars dans panic fois
plaisir chaque projet parce qu'il ya des
mots qu'on est pas mal c erie peut être
nous a eu beaucoup bien ah ouais donnez
vous une fois ou deux fois par mois une
fois pas une fois par mois
ça prend des organismes comme ceux qui
peuvent aider les gens puis c'est fouet
tout si chaleureux four est tellement
fouet faut pas juger car la personne
arrive faut la prendre comme elle est
très fière de ce que je fais souvent sa
première fois qu'on me pose cette
question là je suis fier de ce que je
fais mais principalement pour une raison
parce que on peut rien faire seul
qu'est ce qui fait que les fonctions
vous une belle mobilisation des
communautés
il ya un conseil d'administration il ya
une direction tient toute cette équipe
mais il ya aussi beaucoup de générosité
d'entre aide et je dirais aussi en
comblant qu'on utilise peut-être plus ou
moins il ya beaucoup d'éthique dans la
façon de faire les choses et de rendre
les services à la population
c'est près de 700 personnes qui
bénéficient chaque mois de l'aide de
moisson valais et à l'échelle du québec
via les dix neuf mois sont ces 500 mille
personnes où vous voyez l'organisme
indien
j'aimerais ça être pullo quel problème
de société de pauvreté soit réglée que
tous et chacun est revenu décent pour
vivre correctement
on sait jamais à qui ça peut arriver et
puis on est toujours plus proche que
l'on pense de quelqu'un qui a besoin des
documents
[Musique]